السلام عليكم ورحمه الله ملامح ازمه جديده
بين واشنطن وطهران وتصعيد امريكي خرج من
دائره التراشق الديبلوماسي والحسابات
الانتخابيه الى لائحه عقوبات جديده وواسعه
على ايران ما كشفته التصريحات الامريكيه
وتغريدات الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب هو
ان الامر يتجاوز التجربه الصاروخيه
الايرانيه الى ما يبدو كشف حساب اوسع
وابعد مدى ترى فيه واشنطن ان ميراث اوباما
وسياسته تجاه طهران طواهم
التاريخ ايران من جانبها توخت خطابا
مختلفا وقالت انها لن تبادر بشن حرب او
باستعمال سلاحها الا دفاعا عن النفس تصريح
لافت يدفع الى الواجهه بسؤال الى اي مدن
ستمضي سيناريوهات
التصعيد لم يلبث ان عين ريكس تيلرسون
رسميا وزيرا الخارجيه الامريكيه حتى حسم
الرئيس الامريكي موقفه ازاء ايران فبعد
اقل من 24 ساعه على هذا التعيين امتلات
صفحه الرئيس دونالد ترامب على تويتر
بعبارات الش والتحذير لايران على انتهاكها
قرار مجلس الامن الدولي باطلاقها صاروخا
بالستيا لكن طهران ردت بان تحدت اداره
ترامب بتعهدها بمواصله العمل على تطوير
برنامجها الصاروخي وباستخدام مسؤوليها
عبارات من قبيل تمريغ انف امريكا في
التراب وهي العبارات التي قد تكون استفزت
اداره رئيس امريكي يحرص منذ يومه الاول في
البيت الابيض على الظهور بصوره القوي
الحازم اذ سرعان ما جاء رده بان فرضت
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على طهران
شملت 13 فردا وث هيئه ترتبط بتقديم الدعم
لبرنامج ايران الصاروخي وفيلق القدس
التابع للحرس الثوري
الايراني اليوم فرضت الولايات المتحده
عقوبات على 25 شخصا وكيانا يوفرون الدعم
لبرنامج ايران للصواريخ الباليستيه وفيلق
القدس ان هذه العقوبات جاءت ردا على
مواصله طهران برنامج الصواريخ البالستيه
بما فيه التجربه الصاروخيه في الثام عش من
يناير الماضي فضلا عن مواصلتها دعم
الارهاب لقد اتخذنا هذه الاجراءات وسوف
نواصل الرد باجراءات مناسبه في سياق
جهودنا المستمره لاستهداف برنامج ايران
للصواريخ البالستيه ونشاطاتها الارهابيه
بصرامه شديده تبع هذه العقوبات تحريك
بارجه بحريه الى با المب وهي خطوات بحسب
مسؤولين كبار بالاداره الامريكيه مجرد
خطوات اوليه ردا على سلوك ايران
الاستفزازي ان الهدف من هذه التحركات هو
ارسال اشاره مفادها ان هذه الاداره جاده
في محاوله احتواء ايران مع ضمان تمسكها
بالاتفاق النووي الاداره عقيده العزمه على
تقليص دعم ايران للانشطه الارهابيه ولملي
الشيات التي تحارب في العالم العربي نيابه
عنها يستصعب مراقبون التكهن بالخطوات
التصعيد الاخرى التي يمكن ان تتخذها اداره
ترامب من اجل تحقيق اهدافها في تقويم نهج
ايران في المنطقه كما تقول لكن الواضح ان
سياسه اداره ترامب لن تكون بذات الطيبه
التي اتبعتها اداره اوباما بحسب وصف
الرئيس الامريكي الذي يرى انها لم تكن
ناجعه مع ايران واكبر شاهد على ذلك في
رايه هو واستمرارها في مضايقه الزوارق
الامريكيه لدرجه اطلاقها النار على فرقاطه
سعوديه ظنا من الايرانيين انها امريكيه
بحسب مسؤولين في
واشنطن للحديث عن هذه القضيه انضموا الينا
من واشنطن برادلي بلاكمان المستشار السابق
للرئيس جورج بش ومن طهران الدكتور محمد
مرندي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
طهران نرحب بضيفي سيد برادلي بلاكمان هذا
التصعيد او التوتر المتجدد في العلاقات
الامريكيه الايرانيه الى اين يسير هذه
المره هو لم يكن تصعيدا نحن تم
استفزازنا من قبل ايران حيث انتهكت قرار
مجلس الامن الدولي في اختبارها للصواريخ
اذا فهذا رد بالتالي على استفزاز من
الايرانيين وقد كان
ردا مضبوطا هذه المره ولكن مصير ايران
ومستقبل ايران يعتمدان على مدى استفزازها
للولايات المتحده لكن هناك امر مؤكد وهو
ان دونالد ترامب الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
هو ليس باراك اوباما ونقول لايران اذا ما
لعبت بالنار فسوف تحترقين لكن ايران تقول
بانها لن تكون البادئه بالحرب رغم ما تقول
سيد بلاكمان بان ايران استفزت الولايات
المتحده ماذا عساها فاعله السيد الكتور
محمد
مرندي لا اعتقد ان ايران قلقه على الاطلاق
اولا ايران لم تنتهك الاتفاقيه النوويه
وليس هناك شيء مذكور بالنسبه للصواريخ وهي
لم تنتهك قرار مجلس الامن الدولي لان
هذا سلاح تقليدي وهو دفاعي بطبيعته وقد تم
انتاجه لمنع انظمه مثل الولايات المتحده
من ان تكون قادره على القيام بهجمات ضد
ايران الامر الجيد بالنسبه للايرانيين هو
ان ترامب كسب الانتخابات لانه كان قادرا
على اقصاء وابعاد كثير من الدول اي
الصينيين والاسترالي والمكسيك
وحتى رئيس المجلس الاوروبي الذي دع ترامب
بانه تهديد اذا هذا السلوك بالاضافه الى
التصعيد في اوكرانيا الذي خلق توترات مع
روسيا هذا يعزل الولايات المتحده ويمنعها
من ان تكون كفاه وقادره على الصعيد
الدبلوماسي اذا بالفعل الناس الان يدركون
ان اداره ترامب بسبب قيامها
بمكافحه وقت
كثير من الدول بانها اداره غير معقوله سيد
برادلي بلاكمان قلت بان ليس هناك تصعيد من
الجانب الامريكي و بانما هذه المواقف
الامريكيه جاءت كرد فعل على ما وصفته ب
انتهاك ايران لقرار مجلس الامن الدولي
الخاص بتجربه الصاروخيه ولكن مواقف ترامب
معروفه منذ الحمله الانتخابيه الرجل منذ
الحمله الانتخابيه وهو يتوعد ايران ويهدد
بنقد الاتفاق
النووي الايراني
الغربي هل الا تتحسب اداره ترامب لشركاء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في هذا
الاتفاق وهو الاتفاق الذي ليس بثنائي
امريكي ايراني وانما ايراني
غربي نحن سنفعل ما هو في صالح الولايات
المتحده وحلفائنا اي اسرائيل وسمعتم من
الدكتور مرندي بانه يعتقدون بان ضعف
امريكا هو فرصتهم لاستغلال هذا من خلال
المثال الذي ذكره اي الدول الاخرى
وعلاقاتها مع امريكا وهذا ليس صحيح لكن هو
يصور ان هذه الدول تتحول ضد امريكا ولكن
امريكا اذا ما نظرت الى ايران اذا ما نظرت
الى امريكا بانها ضعيفه في ينبغي ان تعيد
حساباتها فنحن لسنا ضعفاء الامر مؤسف ولكن
ليست الولايات المتحده هي التي انتهكت
قرار مجلس الامن الدولي بل الايرانيون
وبكل خطاب ترامب خلال حملته الانتخابيه لم
يقم باي شيء الى الان كرئيس
ليثير الاجراءات التي قامت بها ايران الا
انه قام الان برد فعل على استفزازات ايران
بفرض عقوبات وهذا كان ردا بالمثل لما قامت
به ايران لا لك سمعت سيد بلاكمان مستشار
خامنئي اليوم حينما قال بان الولايات
المتحده امريكيه اضعف من ان تواجه ايران
عسكريا تعليقك على
ذلك واضح بانه لم يقرا قرار مجلس الامن
الدولي اي المتعلق باختبار صواريخ تقليديه
وهذا لا علاقه له بالقرار وهذا ليس انتهاك
بالتالي اذا فترامب الان يستخدم هذا فرصه
لخلق تصعيد ونحن رايناه يقوم بذلك مع دول
اخرى على مدى الايام القليله الماضيه
والان هم
يتحدثون حتى عن اعاده النظر في علاقتهم مع
كوبا اذا فالمجتمع الدولي الان ينظر الى
هذا الامر وسياسه الصين الواحده وبحر
الصين الجنوبي و التاجي في المعارك في
اوكرانيا فالمجتمع الدولي ليس
غير قادر على ان ينظر ويرى سلوك واشنطن
اذا فليس هناك تعاطف مع ترامب حتى في وطنه
البلد منقسم اذا فايران تعمل في اطار
القانون الدولي وهي واثقه بشان موقفها
وقوتها والولايات المتحده تدرك تماما ان
ايران بلد قوي نافذ واذا ما الولايات
المتحده ارتكبت خطا احمق في مح وي ان
تهاجم ايران فهي ليس فقط لن تكسب ولكن
المجتمع الدولي باسره سوف ينظر الى امريكا
بنظره فيها ادانه وخاصه لما نراه من سلوك
غير منطقي و غير عقلاني من الرئيس الجديد
هل تعتقد سي دكتور مرندي ان الضغط
الامريكي سينعكس على تدخل ايران في ساحات
اخرى في الاقليم في العراق مثلا في سوريا
بالتحديد
اسمعوني انا كنت في حلب قبل ثلاثه اسابيع
وكنت في جامعه حلب وكنت ايضا في جامعه
دمشق واضح تماما بان الناس في سوريا لا
يريدون للمتطرفين الجهاديين الذين تدعمهم
قوى اجنبيه وبشكل غير مباشر من الولايات
المتحده ان يكون هنا في العراق الشعب
العراقي في اغلبيته ايضا قلق ومنزعج بشان
سلوك دول مثل تركيا والولايات المتحده
والسعوديه وفي اليمن الشعب نفسه هو الذي
يقاوم العدوان السعودي والذبح السعودي اذا
ما لم تكن دول مثل السعوديه والولايات
المتحده تنظر الى الواقع فانها سوف تستمر
بالسعي في هذه السياسات المضلله يجب ان
يحترموا شعوب هذه البلاد وشعوب هذه البلاد
هي التي تقاوم اذا ما ايران دعمت الحكومه
السوريه ذلك لانها الحكومه الشرعيه هناك
واذا دعمت الحكومه العراقيه ذلك لانها
الحكومه الشرعيه هناك واذا ما دعمت ايران
شعب اليمن ذلك لانها تقوم بمساعده شعب
يقاوم ويقوم ب مقاومه قصف من النظام
السعودي والتاريخ سيذكر ان السعوديه وحلف
فها دمروا ليبيا وتدخلوا في مصر خلال
الاعوام القليله الماضيه وهذا سبب فقط
دمارا وفي البحرين ايضا هم يضطهدون الشعب
اذا فكل العالم العربي الان يعاني من
الوهابيه ومن التطرف
ومن اموال النفط التي تساعدهم على التدخل
وتساعدهم على التدخل ماذا تفعل ايران ماذا
تف ل لعل السائل يسالك ماذا تفعل ايران في
وهي تدعم
الحوثيين وهي التي انقلبت على الشرعيه في
في اليمن ماذا تفعل ايران في العراق وقد
دعمت تيارا طائفيا ودعمت ايضا
قوى تعيث في الارض فسادا مثل الحش الشعبي
يقول العراقيون ماذا تفعل ايران حينما
تدعم الدكتور عفوا الدكتاتور في سوريا
بشار الاسد لعل الكثير من البعض قد يتحفظ
على ما قلت ولكن بس سؤالي هنا لبرادلي
بلاكمان سيد بلاكمان ترامب في تغريدته
الاخيره قال بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بددت ثلاث
تريليونات من الدولارات في العراق دون ان
تحصل على شيء وقال بان كان من الخطا ان
تخرج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه دون ان
تتمكن من السيطره على على النفط العراقي
هل هل لهذا النهج حيال ايران علاقه بهذا
الامر ه هل تعتقد بان هذا الضغط الامريكي
له ايضا علاقه بتتدخل الايراني في دول
المنطقه خاصه في
العراق اعتقد ان
ايران تدعم الارهاب من بعد وهناك اخرون
يقومون بعملها القذر الماجور راينا هذا
مرارا وتكرارا فهذا هو طريقه عملهم وهذه
طريقه قيامهم بالعمل هم الان يمولون عدم
الاستقرار ويشعرون بانه من مصلحتهم ان
يكون هناك منطقه غير مستقره ولكن الحكومه
مستقره لهم هم يقومون بهذا على مدى عقود
ومازالوا يقومون بذلك والان استفزوا
الولايات المتحده وتحذير لهم هو اذا ما
رايتم ونظرتم الى الولايات المتحده بانها
ا ضعيفه فاننا نحاول ان نبسط الاستقرار في
كل المنطقه اذا فهم يصدرون العنف والارهاب
لانهم يشعرون بان هذا في في صالحهم كما
انهم يهددوننا مباشره من خلال الاستفزاز
بالقيام
باختبار الصواريخ وبناء منشات نوويه يمكن
ان تستخدم لاغراض حربيه فقط هم يعرفون ما
يفعلون
وقد نجوا في كثير من افعالهم خلال اداره
اوباما ولكن اقول لكم ولهم ان ترامب ليس
اوباما ترامب ليس اوباما س بلاكمان ماذا
نتوقع اذا كسلوك عسكري لربما امريكي في
عهد ترامب في العراق بالتحديد الذي بدا هو
متحسرا على يعني التفريط في في النفط
فيه ترامب تعهد للشعب الامريكي والعالم
باننا بحاجه الى ان نخلص المنطقه من تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه ليس دوله واحده فقط ولكن
كثير من الدول الان لها موطئ قدم هناك
بسبب بتدخل ايران اعتقد ان دونالد ترامب
سوف يشكل تحالفا قويا لتخليص هذه المنطقه
من الارهاب والذي هو ليس فقط تهديد
للولايات المتحده بل انه تهديد للسلم في
المنطقه وللعالم باسره اذا دونالد ترامب
لن يقوم باستخدام خيار عسكري اولا ولكنه
لن يطرح اي شيء عن الطاوله فيما يتعلق
بالتدخل العسكري شكرا لك برادلي بكمان
المستشار السابق للرئيس جورج بوش من
واشنطن كما نشكر من طهران الدكتور محمد
مرندي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
طهران ابعاد التصعيد الامريكي الايراني
سيواصل استطلاعها زميل جلال شهده في الملف
الثاني من الحصاد ويقرا في تداعياتها على
الخليج